Hey what's up guys we were back today
with another explosive project now last
night I had an idea come to me for an
improvised desktop weapon so today we're
going to be making alka-seltzer grenades
now the materials for this project are
really about as simple as they can get
you're just going to need a box of
alka-seltzer and some of these little
plastic film canisters that used to be
able to find at photo centers now I got
these ones at Walmart but because
everything's going digital now they're
getting a lot harder to find however you
can find them all over Amazon for about
50 cents each so I'll put a link in the
description to where you can find some
now the reason I like film canisters is
because they're a really good size and
they have a lid that just presses down
into place nice and snug like that but
if you can't find any film canisters
like this and don't feel like buying
them online then just try and find some
other comparable sized container with a snap-on lid like this all right now the
first step to making your Seltzer
grenade is to find yourself a roll of
duct tape I have a few camouflage rolls
left over so I'll be using that and the
nice thing about a roll of duct tape is
the tape is the exact width of the film
canister so we're just gonna need to
wrap this around a couple times and just
like that our grenade casings got a
really cool texture
quick update guys I actually took the
last tape off of the roll it was just
enough to wrap around the container then
I pressed the lid of the container into
another piece of duct tape and use a
pair of scissors to cut around the edges
and did the same with the bottom of the
container as well and here's what we've
got now these white round alka-seltzer
tablets are really what make all the
magic happen and priming your Seltzer
grenade is very simple start by filling
your container about a quarter of the
way full with warm water drop in one
single tablet pop the lid on tight give
it a shake throw it and run awesome the
Seltzer grenade goes off with a bang
makes a pop that'll make anyone jump and
the coolest thing it's completely
reusable not only that but if you catch
it in time most of your Seltzer tablet
will be salvageable as well you can use
it again now this Seltzer grenade was
inspired by the idea of the alka-seltzer
rocket which pretty much works on the
same principle add some water drop in an
alka-seltzer tablet pop on the cap but
stick it upside down so it rests on the
table with the cap facing down the
pressure begins to build and once it's
too much for the container the body
explosively separates and gets thrown
into the air let's do that one more time
in real time we fill it up about a
quarter of the way with water add one
alka-seltzer tablet press on the lid
give it a shake set it down and run away
and you can see just like a real grenade
you get about five to six second delay
alright so let's talk for a second about
exactly what's happening during this
reaction alka-seltzer tablets are made
of three main ingredients they have
aspirin but they also have baking soda
and citric acid which you might remember
are two of the main ingredients we used
for the bath bombs in a previous project
video when the tablets dissolved in
water the bicarbonate reacts with the
hydrogen in the citric acid to Bruce
water and carbon dioxide gas the carbon
dioxide being released builds pressure
until it's substantial enough to burst
the container so now that we've got our
Seltzer grenades down to a science let's
take it to the next level
with airsoft BB's now the setup of our
improvised airsoft grenade is pretty
much gonna be the same the only
difference is we're going to drop in a
handful of around 40 to 50 BBS so we got
our Seltzer tablet on the bottom our
airsoft BB's on the top now we simply
add a bit of water press on the top and
throw it and then get to a safe place
extremely far away
hey that was pretty powerful it was a
good one that's a good one that was what
I was looking for
so there you have guys that is how to
make a mini Seltzer grenade that you
could use just to startle an
unsuspecting victim or declare desktop
warfare on one of your mischievous
cubicle counterparts thanks for joining
me for this video guys let me look for
the next one talk to you then it smells
good
yeah it's effervescent hey guys quick
reminder that limited time king of
random t-shirts are now on sale click
the link at the top of the description
or visit randomgear.com. See you there